[Musique]
ça te fait quoi d'être de retour c'est
super j'ai de si bons souvenirs ici mon
petit coin de paradis pourrait aussi
devenir le nôre qui t'a laissé tout seul
ici j'ai jou un nouveau jeu avec le de
chass au trésor
superas pas le droit de jouer avec nous
parce que tu l'as abandonné il me faut
un truc joyeux un truc
joyeux je croyais que tu avais peur des
insectes si je finis ma liste va
m'emmener en voyage chez
[Musique]
lui quelque chose qui fait
malice tu passes du temps avec un nouvel
ami
faire mal c'était pour
jouer tu crois que c'est ce que voudrait
un véritable ami peut-être qu'on devra
plus jou
peutre qu'on devra plus
[Applaudissements]
elle a disparu mais on va la retrouver
dans toute culture il existe des entités
qui sont lié à l'enfance on les appelle
les amis
imaginaires tu jouis en permanence avec
ton ami imaginaire quand le lien est
rompu l'entité se
déchne il qu'il est juste derrière
toi je ami imaginaire il est pas
imaginaire il est pas ton
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ami